salut dans la présentation de la chaîne
j'explique le point de départ est
l'objectif de ces vidéos
normalement si je réussis c'est la
première fois que je tente il y ait un
lien qui s'affiche ici
maintenant j'aimerais bien vous
présenter les différents formats quand
l'arrière plan est blanc comme si cela
correspond à ce que j'appelle des
propositions je pars du principe que si
une manière de voir les choses m'a aidé
à mieux comprendre un mécanisme
psychologique social ou intellectuelles
ya des chances que ça puisse aider
d'autres gens ces grilles de lecture
forme corps principal de la chaîne j'ai
créé des séries en fonction de la
discipline ou de l'objet d'études et
parfois le titre parle de lui-même
parfois un peu moins apprendre et
comprendre est inspiré de mon expérience
d'enseignant sa touche en somme le
problème de la simulation ou de
l'incorporation dans savoir théorique
science et existence interroge la place
nous faisons la connaissance dans la vie
quotidienne entre rapport à nous-mêmes à
autrui à la politique c'est quand
l'arrière plan est en papier millimétré
comme ceci ou en petits carreaux ou un
gant garraud parce que c'est sympa de
vérité c'est le format bleu que j'ai
ironiquement intitulé to school for
school par manque d'inspiration
ce sera de la vulgarisation proprement
dit en plus de filles principalement
puisque c'est mon domaine de
prédilection mais aussi pourquoi pas
dans d'autres disciplines car j'envisage
de faire des collaborations pour chaque
vidéo j'indiquerai au début son niveau
de précision le niveau 1 signifie que je
n'aurais pas pu faire plus simple
c'est une introduction générale à la
notion à l'auteur ou au courant de
pensée c'est ce que j'espère faire
principalement le niveau 2 correspond à
une focalisation par exemple on pourrait
imaginer faire une vidéo de niveau 1 qui
soit une introduction au stoïcisme
c'est effectivement la première vidéo du
format et ensuite une vidéo de niveau 2
qui se concentrerait sur la question la
logique chez les stoïciens ou sur les
exercices spirituels ou sur la physique
quand je pourrai je vous demanderai à la
fin d'une vidéo de niveau 1
si vous souhaitez une vidéo de niveau 2
sur un point particulier enfin les
vidéos de niveau iii correspondent à une
exploration plus exhaustive et donc plus
difficile elles s'adresseront à celles
et ceux qui ont déjà une expérience du
vocabulaire philosophique il y aura pour
chaque vidéo
une bibliographie et des notes
apparaîtront à l'écran pendant que je
parle comme maintenant
de formanoir est intitulé sketches il
s'agit en moins de trois minutes de
présenter un concept un sentiment une
intuition de faire une expérience de
pensée c'est une stimulation mentale
express sera sûrement un peu provocateur
parfois mais c'est la rapidité du format
qui veut ça néanmoins pour éviter au
maximum les malentendus voilà des petits
logos indicatif hop et renvoie à des
manières de voir les choses des
intuitions des sentiments des pistes de
réflexion c'est pour inviter à réfléchir
c'est la version ultra abrégée du format
blanc en quelque sorte fille cela veut
dire que j'ai c'est de présenter un
concept aussi sérieusement qu'on puisse
le fait en moins de trois minutes
ce peut être des concepts que j'ai
abordés ailleurs ou des concepts que je
développerai dans notre vidéo plus tard
le x indique la volonté de faire une
expérience de philosophie ça pourra donc
être une expérience autour d'un concept
une manière peu orthodoxe de réfléchir
autour d'une idée ou la description
d'exercices mentaux pour entraîner son
esprit un peu à la manière des claques
voilà j'espère que ça vous plaira invite